what about sort of the lifting ties
raise all boats
meaning
if we look at the 20th century right
a lot of people maybe disagree with this
but they attribute a lot of the
innovation and the
average improvement in the quality of
life
uh to capitalism right to inventions and
innovation to engineering
and science developments
that resulted from competition and all
those kinds of forces
so not looking at the individual
unfairness of exploitation as it's
specifically defined but just observing
historically looking at 20th century we
came up with a lot of cool stuff that
seemed to have made life easier
and better
on average
what do you say to that
i have several responses to that um but
i do disagree pretty far fundamentally
with what's going on there but but let
me give you the arguments so you that
you can hear them and then you can
evaluate them
as can anybody who's listening or
watching
um
marx was a student of hegel and one of
hegel's central arguments was that
everything that exists
exists
quote in contradiction
in simple english
there's a good and bad side if you like
to everything
and you won't understand it unless you
accept that proposition and start
looking
for the good things that are the other
side of the bad ones and the bad things
that are the other side of the goodwill
etc
so the dialectic yes exactly and mark's
very attentive to that
explicitly agrees with this on many
occasions
and applies it of course to the central
object of his research
capitalism
so this is not a simple-minded fellow
who's telling you all the bad things
about capitalism as if there were
nothing that this system achieved or
accomplished and one of the things he
celebrates a lot
is
the technological dynamism of the system
which marx takes to be
profound because you know he lived at
the time when major breakthroughs in
textile technology and mining uh and
chemistry and so on were achieved
um
but as to the notion that that
capitalism is therefore responsible
for the improvement in
in the quality or the standard of living
of the mass of people marx comes back
and says oh wait wait a minute here
number one
capitalism as a system
has been mostly represented by
capitalists which makes a certain sense
and those capitalists with very few
exceptions some but very few
have fought against every effort to
improve the lives of the mass of people
the goal of a capitalist is to minimize
labor costs what that means is replace a
worker with a machine
move the production from expensive us to
cheap china
bring in desperate immigrants from other
parts of the world because they will
work for less money than the folks that
you have here at home
uh every measure to help the standard of
living of american workers had to be
fought for
for decades over the opposition of
capitalists from the beginning
to right now
the reason we have a minimum wage which
was past 19 middle of the 1930s
when it was proposed it was blocked by
capitalists they got together they don't
and today
just a factoid for you
the last time the minimum wage was
raised in the united states federal
minimum wage was in 2009
when it was set at the lofty sum of
seven dollars and 25 cents an hour
which you cannot live on
over the last 12 years or so whatever it
is not 11 12 13 years
since then
we have had an increase in the price
level in this country every year
and in the last year eight and a half
percent
during that time that the prices went up
the minimum wage was never raised
what this is a time of stock market boom
of growing inequality this is a
you know
the nerve of the defender of capitalists
who wants now
to get credit for the improvement in the
standard of life of the workers that was
fought by every generation
you know it takes your breath away it's
an argument whoa
but i take my hat off if i had one
because that is one of the only ways to
justify this system
long ago let me get it the heart of it
long ago capitalism
could have
overcome hunger
could have overcome disease
could have i mean way beyond what we
have now
but it didn't yeah and that's the worst
moral
condemnation imaginable how do you
justify
that when you could you didn't
look i let me get at it another way
because this may it may interest you
anyway
the issue is not that capitalism isn't
technologically dynamic it is and along
the way it has developed things that
have helped people's lives get better no
question
but the notion that the
the mass enjoyment of a rising standard
of living is somehow built into
capitalism
is factually nuts
and
is such an outrageous and i can give you
because you do math you'll understand it
think of it this way
imagine a production process in which
you have um
a hundred dollars that the capitalist
has to lay out for tools equipment and
raw materials
and a hundred dollars that he has to lay
out for workers hire the workers and he
puts them all together and he has an
output
and let's say
the output is a hundred units of
something or whatever of the prices
and that's his revenue
and when he when he
takes his product and sells it and gets
the revenue
let's say the revenue is it doesn't
really matter it's
120 for lack of a better word and he
take 220 sorry and he takes 100 of it
and replaces the tools equipment and raw
materials he used up another 100 to hire
the workers for the next shift and the
other 20 is his profit and he puts that
aside
now along comes a technological
breakthrough
a machine a new machine
and the new machine is so effective
you can get the same out the same number
of units of output with half the workers
so you don't need to spend 100 on
workers you only need to spend 50.
you can do it with half the workers
and so the capitalist goes to the
workers by the way this happens every
day and he says to half of them you're
fired
don't come back monday morning i don't
need you it's nothing personal i got a
machine
why does he do that because of the 50 he
now no longer has to spend on labor
because don't need half of them
he keeps everything else is the same the
machine everything else is this just to
make the math easy so he he keeps as his
own profit the 50 that before he paid
for those workers yeah right because
when he sells it for 220 that 50 don't
have to give to the next year because he
has a new machine
so that's what he does
the technology leads
he's happy
he's become more profitable he's got an
extra 50 which is why he buys the
machine
the workers
are screwed
half of them just lost their job have to
go home to their husband and wife tell
them i don't have a job anymore i didn't
do anything wrong the guy was nice
enough to say there was nothing wrong
with me but he doesn't need him
so i'm i'm completely screwed here i
don't know what i'm going to do about
the debts we have the house on mortgage
my children's education or whatever else
he's got going for himself
right now now the point
there was of course an alternative path
the alternative path would have been to
keep all the workers
pay them exactly the same that you did
before
for half a day's work
you would have got the same output
same revenue
same profit as before
the gain of the technology
would have been a half a day of freedom
every day of the lives of these workers
the majority of workers would have been
really
helped
by this technology
but instead they were screwed
so that one guy the employer could make
a big bundle of more money
you want to support a system like this
well uh
to go back to hegel yes the good and the
bad yes
so
you just listed the bad and you also
first listed the good the technological
innovation of this kind of system
the question is the alternative
uh whatever
as we try to sneak up to ideas of what
the alternative might look like right
what are the good and the bad of the
alternative so you just kind of as a
opposite in the contract by contrast
showed that well a nice alternative is
you work less
get paid the same you have more leisure
time right opportunity to to pursue
other
interests other interests the creative
interest family right
flourish as a human being
uh basically uh strengthen and uh
embolden the basic humanity that's under
all of us yes but then
what cost does that have
on the
um
the deadline
fueled
competition-fueled machine
of technological innovation that is the
positive side of capitalism slows it
down it slows it down and the question
is
which is more important for the
flourishing of humanity i love i agree
with that and i'd love there to be
a democratic mechanism so let's let's
discuss it let's debate it and then
let's uh decide what mixture because
it's not either or the math problem i
gave you is either or we could mix it
you could have
a third less of a working day instead of
a half less and then the other part
would be extra profit for our employer
etc so let's have a democratic
discussion
of what is the mix between the positive
and we have no such thing all of this is
decided by one side in this debate which
not only
we know what they do they always choose
the one that maximizes their profit
because that's what they were told to do
in business school where i've taught
right um so we
not only is it an undemocratic decision
but it's lopsided to boot so we don't
have the opportunity but i would love
for us
to be good hegelian marxists and say
let's take a look at the plus and the
minus and make the best decision that we
can
we'll make mistakes but we'll all make
them together it won't be one of us
making a dictatorial decision
you know marx developed the notion of
the dictatorship of the proletariat not
as a notion of how government
is not i'm sorry not marx lennon did
that
not as a notion of how the government
works but as a notion of what the
practical reality is
the dictatorship in these key decisions
is not made by some sitting council it's
made by each little capitalist in his
her relationships with the workers in
the workplace which is why marx focused
his analysis on that point
and by the way i can sketch for you
right now so it doesn't lurk in the
background what the alternative is let's
go there okay it goes right back to what
i said earlier
the workers themselves the collection of
employees
together
appropriate their own surplus and decide
democratically what to do with it which
includes
the decision of whether or not to buy a
machine
and whether or not
to use the machine and the savings it
might allow
to be
handled by more leisure for themselves
or as a fund
for new developments
in technology or new products or
whatever
they want
and you know this this is an old idea in
human marx loved that toward the end of
his life he
he started reading extensively in
anthropology and one of the reasons he
did that toward the end of his life was
because he kept discovering
that in this society in that including
here in the united states
that there were examples
of people who organized
their production in precisely this way
as a collective
democratic
community
in which everybody had an equal voice so
we all together decide democratically
what to produce how to produce where to
produce and what to do with the output
we all help to produce so let's do it in
you know in this country
where
democracy
is a
value nearly everybody subscribes to
think about it this way the stunning
contradiction
that there is a place in our society
where democracy has never been allowed
to enter
the workplace
in the workplace a tiny group of people
unaccountable to the rest of
the the employer whether that's an
individual a family a partnership or a
corporate board of directors tiny group
of people
controls economically a vast mass of
employees those employees don't elect
those people have no con nothing there
is no accountability it is the most
undemocratic
arrangement imaginable
and this society insists on calling
itself
democratic when it has organized the
minor matter of producing everything in
a in a way that isn't the direct it's
autocratic
you